if you need a family
you can come hang out with me
I'd rather be an orphan
do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad arshad Muhammad arshad has
helped develop all of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course definitely
recommend this course
to access the free life-changing
training now assalamualaikum guys
yesterday I was on YouTube scrolling and
I came across the most amazing Channel
smile to gender and I watched the video
and I thought what's going on because I
knew that this Bangor sister on Tick
Tock who does videos which I don't
really watch myself but she was having
an issue or exposing an individual
called Jeffrey Epstein Jeff what was his
name Jeffrey Marsh sorry yeah Jeffrey
Marsh yeah some marshmallow here I don't
know who he is here so and there was a
back and forth going and I saw the
videos and I thought okay this is
interesting what's going on I was
shocked to my core that this guy has a
patron not only that he is calling hey
I mean anybody that goes to any child
and goes hey kitties it's quite
disturbing for me and I'm sure if you're
watching this you're probably vomiting
right now but the point I want to make
is the following there was a back and
forth between them however in the video
that I watched on Smart adjust Channel
she was crying and I thinking why is she
crying
so I just got an email
saying um
pretty much a threat
saying I know they know where I live
and what scares me the most
is um
they have got my daughter's details on
the email
like what time I leave to drop them to
school please don't come at me don't
come to my house don't don't do anything
with me
because I'm just one person one person
she went to the level of deleting those
videos because her car was attacked she
was being blackmailed she received an
email or somebody actually tracking her
taking her kids to school what time
where she drops him off because she's
got two kids and they go to two
different schools so they're trying to
threaten and blackmail her I Dare You
cowards to come and try that with me
okay now let's unravel all of this let's
take a step at a time now
as parents and my parents I have two
daughters I'm sure if you guys are
watching you might have kids or you
might not have kids but imagine
imagining your kids what they would be
going through in this very instance now
where do we entrust our kids there's
certain places family members schools in
schools you have teachers you entrust
these teachers and you leave your
children with these teachers in the
school parameters that they are safe and
they're safeguarding in place and
there's regulatory regulatory bodies
which are keeping the kids in safe place
a teacher is not allowed to have any
kind of communication by themselves
outside the school premises with your
child and with my child
not just bear this in mind and just
imagine that teacher or whoever forget a
teacher some
weird looking man some man some boy or a
man yeah this man is saying the
following to your kids let's hear it for
ourselves then
we're going to go to a very very nice
song that I'm going to dedicate to this
individual I believe music is Haram but
I am going to show it to you guys
because I think every child has to learn
these lyrics we'll come to that in a
minute but let's watch how Jeffrey Marsh
is talking to your kids hi kids
hey kids I want to talk to the kid
if I was going through YouTube and I saw
that I would flick my phone you're gonna
rely on I'll throw it against the wall
hey kids hey Google what hell is this
I'm sure he doesn't have anything
alarming that any child or anyone for
that matter be it a Jewish Christian
Muslim Hindu atheist secular you name it
any of these individuals who are parents
would have a problem with I'm sure they
don't
what does he it's about Jeff and I
having sex
and are you allowed to talk about that
on patreon listen I'm ready for the
asteroid I've had enough
um as far as I know anyone's going at
some way of morality left in them
doesn't seem like you do uh you should
not be talking about them patreon but
but but but if you're from the lgbtqt
community if you identify as trans and
if you identify whatever you can talk
whatever you like nobody can say nothing
to you I identify as someone who decides
what your pronouns are how about that
how about I identify as somebody who
decides a regulatory body who gives a
certificate to me deciding what your
pronouns are he's talking about intimacy
sex with his I don't know boyfriend or
girlfriend I don't know anything about
this person yeah he's talking about
intimacy now is that scary
yes you can say that it's very scary but
look what he says now about no contact I
will tell you about
about no contact
so you've
moved if you are family
what kind of a life is that no no let's
be real what kind of a flipping love is
that what is this
and I agree no contact you should have
no contact with anyone let alone kids
you should have no contact I agree no
contact he's trying to divorce yes
symbolically the child from their family
their parents guess who he wants the new
kids that he wants to take away from
their actual biological family who cares
about them who's nurtured them who would
die for them guess who their new family
is going to be if you need a family
you can come hang out with me
I'd rather be an orphan
I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'd rather be an orphan than be your
family all day every day I swear to God
I mean I I would prefer anything in this
world except having you as my family
let me be very strange I'm laughing
because I have no choice but I'm gonna
end on this note brothers and sisters
yeah okay here is the final video that I
want to show you guys
and I dedicate this kid's song which has
been taught in schools
to everybody
this is for you Jeffrey Marsh if you
ever come across any stranger or someone
like Jeffrey Marsh who speaks to you
like this you say the following
[Music]
I dedicate this song to Jeffrey Marsh
and anybody from the lgbqt community
yes whoever you are If You Think You're
Gonna blackmail us and when I say us I
am talking about not only the Muslims
who are standing who are the last people
who are standing against your immorality
not only that not that you want to be
gay or trans you can be whatever you
like the point is that you are now
shoving it down our throats the Muslims
the Jewish Community the Christian
Community the Hindu Community the Sikh
Community the Hindu Community I think I
mentioned atheists all of them are going
to be a obstacle in your way we are not
going to let you come and consume our
children
best believe that and the first that you
send into this Bengali sister
which I'm trying to get in contact with
I dare you to come and try that with me
or anyone else for that matter we are
not scared of you you are not going to
Blackmail us we have the freedom of
speech to talk and speak out against you
and you and your community has become
not only toxic you guys have become
radical individuals you are radical so
much so that Muhammad went to Ireland to
give a talk and you guys who were
Advocates of freedom of speech
decided to stop him maybe directly or
indirectly yes because of security
issues the event was canceled
we can see your freedom of speech
we can see what you are trying to do we
see right through you just know till our
last breath
we will be in your way intellectually
challenging your hypocrisy and your
double standards
that was my freedom of speech if you
genuinely believe in freedom of speech
you will hit the like button share it
with your friends and family and comment
and say I support you
that's what I'm going to say
for now
stranger danger Stranger Danger get back
Jeffrey Marsh you're not my dad fire
fire call 9-1-1
that's why you do kids inshallah and may
Allah protect our children and this
sister who is going through this yeah
who has made you've made her cry yeah
she's our sister in Islam yeah okay
and if needed we will have brothers in
front of her house and I will volunteer
firstly I will volunteer and if I'm
joking I will volunteer to be in front
of a house and keeping making sure that
none of these cowards come and dare to
blackmail her the peaceful lgbqt
community yeah that's the true face of
the LGBT community promises the LGBT
community okay they attack her faith
they attack her weight so much so
they'll send them sharing pictures of
her in non-non no hijab this is how low
they become they would say you know
we've got no problem with Muslims until
you speak out against them then you will
be thrown under the bus
We Fear the lgbtqt community more than
the far right the far right one two take
hours take our body
the fathers want to take our soul they
want to corrupt our children and we're
not going to allow that
that's it brother and sisters until next
time
please send this to Jeffrey Marsh
whatever his name is yes and let's see
if he has any comebacks or anything to
say till then please report his patreon
report his patreon for in this indecency
and safeguarding and code prevents as
well